في المقابل الحضري المتحدث باسم الكرملاند
متري بيسكوف من ان تسليما كيف دبابات
سيترك اثرا لا يمحى على العلاقات مع برلين
وقال بسكوب ان عمليه تسليم هذه لن تاتي
باي خير على العلاقات بين روسيا والمانيا
مستقبلا
العلاقات
لا تحمله خيرا بالنسبه للعلاقه في
المستقبل سيكون لها بلا شك اثر حتمي على
مستقبل تلك العلاقات
رجعتي قال السفير الروسي لدى واشا انا
اصلي ان تنوف ان الرساله واسطه المحتمل
للدبابات الى اوكرانيا استفزاز صاروخ جديد
واضاف ان تنظف في تصريحات عبر تطبيق
التليجرام انه اذا حاولت واشطا تبريره تلك
الخطوه بانها تاتي في اطار تزويد اوكرانيا
باسلحه دفاعيه فان هذه الحجاج لن تجدي وفق
تعبئه وقال ان تنظف انه من الواضح تحاول
عن قصد الحلقه هزيمه الاستراتيجيه بروسيا
واضاف انه في حاله تم تسليم ودبابات
ابرامز الامريكيه لاوكرانيا في سيتم
تدميرها من قبل الجيش الروسي
بريمير
الدبابات
الامريكيه قبلها ايضا موقف تجاه المانيا
وان العلاقات ستكون مختلفه كيف نفهم
استقبال موسكو للموافقات الالمانيه
والامريكيه على هذه الدبابات الداخله الى
المعركه
تترقب هذا القرار في موسكو تعتبر ان كل
الدول الاوروبيه وعلى راسي الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه وهذا ما قاله
وزير الخارجيه الروسيه ليست مستقله
بقرارها همم سياسي وانا الامر همم ياتي من
الولايات المتحده بشكل مباشر مما سيعقد
برايه الاخرين او براي عفوا رؤوس تسويه
الازمه حول اوكرانيا موسكو قالت انها
ستدمر كما فعلت مع مختلف على اليات التي
قدمتها الدول شمال
على قسم كبير من المعدات العسكريه
الاوكرانيه وتلك التي قدمت من قبل الحلف
شمال الاطلس هناك نقص واضح براي موسكو
المعدات الثقيله وخاصه الدبابات الان هنا
مراكز دراسات العسكريه تتحدث ان هذا هذه
ال ال هذا الدخول الجديد همم للمعطى
الجديد للاسلحه الثقيله الامريكيه
والالمانيه الى ساحت المعركه هو تحدي ليس
فقط بالنسبه للروسي وايضا الى ما كانت
وجودت هذه الاسلحه التي برايها الاجانب
الروسي لم تدخل فعليا حرب تقليديه همم
مناطق معقده جغرافيا بمناطق موحده
كالاراضي همم سوفيتها السابقه اراضي
اوكرانيا واراضي روسيا وبالتالي همم سيكون
هناك تحدي كبير امام همم هذه الصناعه
العسكريه الغربيه فيما يتعلق بالعمليات
على الارض وسيم ان هناك تساؤلات كبيره حول
القدره هذه الاليات بالقتال على همم في
مناطق بارده ومناطق همم
ذكر هذا من ناحيه من ناحيه ثانيه روسيه
تعتبر وهذا ما اقده امسى نائب رئيس مجلس
الامن الروسي ميتري مدربي انا همم ادخال
او الزج همم
اوكرانيا بمعدات ث همم فعليا يقرب
المواجهه المباشره بين روسيا وانيتو انا
وانا الامر اصبح لم يعد حربا هجينه او
حربا بالوكاله هي حرب مباشره القوات حلف
شمال الاطلسي تدخل بكامل قوتها ولكن ايضا
ذكر كما ذكر في نفس اليوم ايضا سردي
الابروف ذكر الالمان وذكر الفرنسيين
بالتاريخ ذكرهم بالحرب العالميه الثانيه
عندما هزمت المانيا وذكر ايضا الفرنسيين
همم في همم حربهم ضد روسيا ابانه حكم
الامبراطور نابليون بونابر وبالتالي همم
براي موسكو تاريخ ويعيد نفسه ويعيد نفسه
همم نفس الاخطاء وانا لا يمكن وهذا ما كذه
ايضا الرئيس الروسي لا يمكن لاي دوله
نوويه
تخسر حربا تقليديه بمعنى ان التاريخ لم
يعرف هزيمه دوله نوويه في حروب تقليديه في
اشاره مباشره لان الروس يمكن ان تقدم على
كل الخيارات مقابل بقائها منتصر في هذه
الحرب محمد شكرا جزيلا لك مدير مكتب
الجزيره من موسكو ظهر شلش